Dans la Chapelle Notre-Dame-de-
Bon-Secours dans le Vieux
Montréal résonnent
des airs inhabituels.
♪ ♪ ♪
Comme le fameux Thriller de
Michael Jackson interprété par
un quatuor à cordes.
♪ ♪ ♪
C'est qu'on y présente
actuellement des concerts
à la bougie sous la thématique
halloween.
JULIEN OBERSON, Violoniste
- Ce n'est pas tout le monde
qui connaît la musique
classique, pas tout le monde
qui aime ça aller l'écouter
et pourtant on a beaucoup de
gens qui viennent découvrir ce
répertoire là via nos concerts.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Avec cet éclairage favorisant
l'introspection et la réflexion,
les musiciens proposent
un répertoire varié et lumineux.
- En fait, on a un répertoire
mixte; on a des chansons plus
classiques et des chansons plus
populaires. Aussi,
des programmes pop et
des programmes de musique de
film et ça, le mariage des deux,
ça plait beaucoup aux gens,
ce qui fait que plusieurs
univers se rencontrent et ça,
c'est intéressant autant
pour nous comme musiciens
que pour le public.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Des concerts sans prétention
qui réussissent à attirer
un nouveau public.
- C'est un premier concert de
musique classique,
donc quelque chose qu'on voulait
faire depuis longtemps.
- C'est sûr la thématique
Halloween. Fait que pour nous
trois ça a été plus attrayant,
mais je pense que c'est
une belle initiation pour venir
à l'avenir en voir d'autres.
- J'aime bien la musique et puis
c'est bien de revoir des gens
et d'avoir beaucoup de gens
dans une salle.
ALEXANDRE BOCCARDI, Responsable
événements, Fever Canada
- On a environ 70 % de notre
public qui est âgé entre
18 et 40 ans. Donc, pour
une grande partie d'entre eux,
c'est leur première expérience
de musique classique.
- L'objectif des organisateurs
est : proposer des expériences
thématiques qui passent par
la musique, mais pas seulement.
- C'est certain que la musique,
c'est effectivement un des
éléments les plus importants,
mais c'est pas le seul; donc,
jumelé avec des salles qui sont
impressionnantes avec toutes
les chandelles qui sont dans
le concert, on essaie de créer
une expérience qui est très
complète.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Une façon de démocratiser
la musique classique, d'attirer
de nouveaux adeptes et de
renouveler le public.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.-
♪ ♪ ♪